well joined by the chair of the defense
select committee Tobias Elwood who's in
Odessa in Ukraine this morning hello to
Mr Elwood it's good to see you thanks
for joining us um first of all why are
you there
well firstly to better understand what
is actually happening here we're at a
critical uh juncture in this War uh with
Russia and there's huge appreciation I
should say for the British commitment to
what we've done to help ukrainians push
back the the third largest army in the
world and but Putin is now humiliated
and there's huge concerns that he's
going to go more extreme he's going to
find uh more imaginative way ways to
raise the stakes and uh he's starting to
regroup the other side of the danipa
river and it's so important that that
message is said at the G20 as the Prime
Minister has been underlying that we
don't give up now that we don't sign a
deal that we don't step back but we're
able to flush Russia completely out of
Ukraine and that's certainly the strong
message that that we're getting here
myself and the defense Select Committee
do you think that President Putin should
have attended the G20 Summit in Bali
yes understandably why he didn't the
last time he turned up uh at a an
International Conference uh he was
humiliated I think by the Indian Prime
Minister and others who said what are
you doing in Ukraine so he sent lavrov
uh instead but ultimately uh lavrov is
just going to give us the lines that uh
uh Putin is spouting to say that this is
nobody else's business it is our
business because you know the Green
Ships behind me are not moving as as
they should do and uh Security in
Eastern Europe is everybody's security
if we don't flash Russia out of Ukraine
now how can Ukrainian economy move
forward how can the Sovereign identity
of Ukraine exist this is the time to do
it if we sign any deal now all Russia
will do is regroup to attack again in a
year or two's time it has to happen now
I thought a deal had been done as far as
the grain was concerned bread basket of
Europe of course to get it out of uh
Odessa and to parts of the world that
need it most what happened
yeah I mean but this shows that Russia
has continued to be setting the agenda
we've been following it this was
Russia's deal and they controlled the
movement of ships but actually this as I
suggested before should be an
international humanitarian Safe Haven
with the UN stamp of approval that
removes Russia from it you have you know
Ukrainian territorial Waters here
linking up to international waters in
the Black Sea that should have nothing
to do with Russia yet Russia is the one
that set this deal and only one-fifth of
those chips are actually leaving this
port meaning that the world Africa and
indeed Europe has not been fed on the
scale and of course that causes rises in
food prices knock-on inflation problems
elsewhere so we need to lean further
into this this is the moment now to take
the responsibility of this um a port
away from from Russia back to Ukraine
and the International Community
there have been some successes we've
seen what's happened in Curson and we've
seen that president zielinski has gone
along to um congratulate his troops and
also to offer uh Solace and support to
those that live then have lived under
Russian control for the last eight
months but Jen stoltenberg NATO
Secretary General has urged the West not
to make the mistake of underestimating
Russia you would agree with that
a hundred percent I mean firstly occurs
on is massively humiliating for uh Putin
they've had to withdraw across the
danipu river but the Russia still has
control of you know the size of Portugal
in Ukraine so this is far from over so
again stolenberg is absolutely right uh
to encourage NATO members to continue
providing that individual bilateral
support as Britain is doing because
Munitions and so forth weapon systems
they need to keep going the back the
battle is actually moving away from the
battlefield as I said with Putin
attacking electricity electric
electricity and infrastructure and so
forth trying to uh break the morale of
the of the Ukrainian people by you know
freezing them out this winter but at the
moment the actual uh there is a lull in
war fighting because there will be a
spring offensive and that's what we need
to build up and prepare for
although anzalenski looking at these
pictures has said that this illustrates
the beginning of the end of the war do
you not agree with him
no no absolutely I do because it's
showing that Russia can't uh hold the
line that uh the Ukrainian defensive the
incredible fighting will of the
Ukrainian forces
um are able to then push back but this
isn't the moment as I say uh to sign
that deal to leave Russia in control of
part of Ukraine it requires additional
effort it means another six months or a
year if you like
um of what we're doing now and the worry
is is that the West's interest
commitment that so far will start to
drain away we we don't have good form on
this if you look at all the places that
we've been to to try and provide you
know a Force for good from Libya Somalia
um Afghanistan Iraq Syria and so forth
we've actually given up and gone home
leaving problems there we mustn't do the
same here this is in everybody's
interest but particularly of course
Ukraine's that we stay here uh and see
this through
where does this leave us when it comes
to how much of our GDP we will be
spending on defense going forward we
know that Liz trust said that that was
going to be three and a half percent uh
when pushed Rishi sunak said to me
during the summer about
um two and a half percent although Ben
Wallace said that when he was at the
treasury he was forced to say that he
was overruled by the Prime Minister and
the ladies were Hearing in the papers
this morning as it could be less than
two and a half percent our defense
budget what would you say in response
yeah well we're slowly understanding and
appreciating why hard power matters why
a strong defense is absolutely critical
to defend our interests whether they're
around the UK or actually here in uh
Ukraine there is a symbiotic
relationship between our economy between
our prosperity and our ability to trade
around the world and the world is
getting more dangerous not less so we
drop our guard at our Peril that will
affect our economy and I hope that's the
message that we'll hear on Thursday from
the chancellor who he himself as former
foreign secretary recognizes the
importance there's also an absence of
International Leadership dare I say we
are doing much better at stepping
forward encouraging others to follow
it's tougher to do that if you don't
have the hard power yourselves to
provide that example
um we're hearing that the traditional
G20 Family Photos actually been called
off one wonders how much this Summit
might actually achieve but then you look
at the fact that the Chinese leader and
the U.S president have got together face
to face for the very first time does
that give you
um some sucker
I think we should always uh welcome uh
conversations between the two world's
largest Powers China and the United
States absolutely but I for one will not
you know drop my guard in in being
concerned about where China is going in
the long term and its symbiotic
relationship with Russia despite what
they say publicly in our lifetimes China
will become uh Stronger larger than the
United States militarily economically
technology technology and that's
important to understand as to how we
manage that how we actually defend our
International values and standards which
China is Keen to exploit so of course we
welcome these talks but don't you know
kill ourselves that China still wants to
uh is watching carefully what's going on
here because it still wants to lay claim
to Taiwan
um a final thought before I let you go
in on domestic politics
um Liz truss and her then
um Chancellor uh not Rishi sunak of
course quasi kwashing apparently uh
their mini budget cost the UK economy
something like 34 billion pounds in just
six weeks they've both gone now they're
entitled to 18
000 and 16
000 pounds severance pay if you will
each
um should they take her
well there's other examples of ministers
who have been in office for a very short
time uh offering to give that money back
to the taxpayer or indeed to charity and
so forth I think it's for those two
individuals to work out what they should
do I would say though that it has been a
very difficult uh summer there's no
doubt about it but I've had faith in the
the British democracy the parliamentary
system we are able to flush out you know
a leader uh a government if we're going
in the wrong direction uh and we can do
that quite ruthlessly in a short period
of time unlike other countries United
States for example where if you do get a
leader that's going to take you in the
wrong direction you have to wait four
years so there is a positive there but
ultimately the details you're talking
about it's for the individuals I think
to recognize and do the right thing
what would you do would you give the
money back
yes I think I I I I think there is no
justification for that short short
period of time I'd have become necessary
conversations
um and uh and make sure that you do do
the right thing you've got to be able to
in politics be able to look in the
mirror and say yes I made the right
decision
good to talk to you as always safe
journey back look forward to seeing you
in the studio soon thank you